so that was all really abstract and
flowery and algebraic you need to see it
with some actual numbers okay so this
one I just pulled out it's literally I
think the first freshman for exercise
similar kind of setup from what you see
in before now you're so used to things
like saint pythagoras pythagoras old
happy you guys so long that when you see
this you almost involuntarily work out
what the last link is you're like no I
know I can do this this square that's
when and then you can work out your
final legs okay and just the same way
you have someone knows here you can use
the surrounding information to find it
out here's the key remember
remember we've been saying it's really
important that you name things properly
and you pay attention to those things so
for example that a be sign see you've
got to know that this angle is opposite
which side it's whichever side you've
labeled Whittlesea now the same way here
when you look at all of these guys here
right these are names very purposefully
so when you want an angle you've got to
match it to its opposite side yeah and
when you want this angle which isn't be
a different one you need to match it to
its opposite side so if you have another
color there have a look and can you see
which sides match with which angles in
fact I need another color so for example
can you see 10.6
matches with 38 see there they are
opposite each other
and in a similar way and unknown in your
off time annex isn't that the opposite
the 21 Hey does that make sense so I'm
going to use this pairing X and 21
degrees 10.6 and 38 degrees I'm gonna
use it with this to work out my own nut
now underneath what you've written this
I want you to write one more thing on it
but it's still the same one but
sometimes you see it upside down like
this
yeah
don't wait yourself out too much now as
we go clear in a second
this form to be more useful for this
question as we're solving it I wonder if
the codes can turn you can work out why
I prefer this one to that one even
though they really say the same thing so
you have been about it that's call it
just yet that's okay I'm just going to
use two parts of this you can use three
depending on the questions I only need
two so I need a length and its opposite
angle I'm gonna start with the one I
don't know that's X and its opposite
angle which is 21 degrees now this is
the sine rule so I'm gonna say sine 21
great so that's the first part over here
I've slaughtered the length where it
belongs and the opposite angle
what's it equal to
okay I thought I've got a length I'm
angle so I'm going to go another length
on sign of the other angle you following
so fine which is 38 degrees
okay now you set it up you slotted
everything in place
I just want X by itself so I should
multiply through by sine 21 degrees so
that leaves me with this and that's just
fodder for your calculator
no more mental calculation required can
someone reach for theirs and give me
maybe young we've got one s if I see you
can I get one there so place from
someone nothing but today yeah anyone
University
okay so once you finish that on should
put your hands down
let's just discuss two quick pointers
about this number one I always ask you
guys when you're measuring something do
a sense check okay now you can enter the
super-talent sense check on this and
I'll show you how right firstly six it's
ten minutes do you think it's okay okay
it's roughly all right but you can do
better than that
what I want you to do is I want you to
stick your arms in front of you not too
wide so you don't get the people beside
you and what I want you to imagine is
the two arms you have I like two legs in
a triangle okay like Senate right now
here's one of what's your thing if you
got your hands in front of you right
you've got an angle wait you are right
do you see you feel forming an angle are
you yes now I want you to think about
what's the size of the angle you've got
right now okay like I don't know mine's
like well that's it that's 90 degrees
right there so if you got a half that's
like 45 think about whether the science
of that is now not only do you have an
angry where you are
but opposite you between your hands you
gotta sign he like visualize that
there's a side going in between okay
now think about this as the angle where
you are gets bigger what happens to the
length of the side they both change
portably and the angle gets bigger the
sign also gets bigger does that make
sense
Mike look he's like a little angle and a
little side in between my hands and he's
a big angle and a really big sight you
agree now come back to our triangle or
comes your pressure in one second
see how this angle is smaller than this
angle do you see it so they're full of
this side must be smaller than this side
because if you make a smaller angle that
force is smaller side just like you
wanted it does that make sense and this
like you said it's smaller
okay am I just gonna have the biggest
the side that you're making between yeah
this one right okay
I'm Bosque will point out this a
question just ask me which I can see on
remember I said to you two different
versions of assignment is the one ever
it down what we all wrote an under there
and then there's this song which is
upside down okay now what would have
happened had I used that version I
wouldn't get the wrong answer but just
watch just watch all the numbers are you
saying it's just gonna look like this
there's the sign whatever on this and
then there's the sign of the other angle
fond yes now it's still gonna give you
the right answer but do you see why I'm
trying to avoid it because look the X
that I want right I don't want you in
there that's icky I guess the first
thing I would do is turn everything
upside down but that just lands you here
so you might as well just kind of go
straight there yes I can amass Rebecca
question how do you decide which one to
use do you use this one or this one
what were you trying to find in this
question what was the unknown it was a
side it was on leg right so therefore
make the length the theme you're trying
to find put it front and center right at
the top use whichever form who put the
thing you want up there if I were trying
to find an angle which we're gonna look
at later I would not use this form I
would use this form you said because the
angles are exactly where I want to mix
it okay